in today's morning rounds a new study
estimates more than one in ten older
Americans binge drink
that's an increase from the previous
decade binge drinking is defined as five
or more drinks at a time for men and
four more drinks at a time for women the
study of this morning determined binge
drinkers 65 and older were more likely
to be men they're also more likely to
use tobacco or cannabis
researchers say the habit can be more
dangerous for older people putting them
at risk for a range of health problems
our dr. Tara Nuala is here to tell us
more doc I I found this really
interesting an estimated 70% of all
hospitalized older persons and up to 50%
of nursing home residents have
alcohol-related problems in general
why is binge drinking specifically
affecting these older Americans well
when we think about binge drinking the
image we usually think about is younger
adults or college students but this is
in fact a growing trend in older
Americans and it's been underreported in
both the scientific literature and in
the media but the problem is that the
alcohol has a very strong effect on
people who are older they're more
vulnerable to the health problems than
even a younger population and when you
look at the percentages as you mentioned
currently around ten point six percent
of older Americans are binge drinkers in
the previous decade it was anywhere from
seven to nine percent so that numbers
growing also growing just general
increased alcohol use and any sort of
harmful alcohol use so is it more
dangerous for older Americans it can be
and there are a couple of reasons why so
they are more sensitive to the alcohol
so they are higher risk of getting
impaired at the same level that might
not impair somebody who's younger many
of them have chronic health problems in
fact in this series twenty to forty
percent of them have things like
diabetes or hypertension or
cardiovascular disease so that can
exacerbate those it can allow them to
develop new problems things like
pancreatitis or gastritis or certain
cancers many of them are on prescription
medications that might interfere and
also it increases the risk of injury or
accidents and Falls and people who
already may have issues with balance or
coordination or reflux and inflammation
and generalized information so are there
guidelines for binge drinking and older
well the recommendations are that really
no American who's older should be
drinking more than three drinks a day
and in fact if you have some sort of
chronic disease or on a prescription
meds should speak to your doctor and
they may recommend something even lower
low-risk drinking is really less than
two drinks a day for a man or one drink
a day for a woman but really important
that doctors really screened for this
and also educate about it because a lot
of these people may be at home drinking
alone nobody really knows what's going
on they the problems may be attributed
to oh they're just getting older that's
why they're more confused and they're
falling so it can be a little bit silent
unless we actually look for it in fact
they said then the metabolism of a
person who's 65 years or older drinking
two or three beers at that age has the
same effect as seven or eight at the age
of twenty right so they're exquisitely
sensitive to it so it's if you what do
you do
very if you have a loved one who's doing
this how do you deal with it that's a
great question because I think a lot of
people tend to shy away from it or they
don't know how to deal with it so and I
think it's important to be compassionate
loving and respectful to these older
Americans who you may feel have a
problem but also you want to be
proactive and so you want to address it
because early intervention is really
essential so you know one of the things
that could be helpful is seeking advice
from a professional can really guide you
towards what type of treatment they
should be getting and interestingly also
how to approach them right should it be
a doctor that approaches them may be a
friend might be better or a family
member and all of the recommendations
really say look don't use the word
alcoholic don't talk to them while they
may be intoxicated wait till they're
sober
be patient be you know direct with them
there it sounds like it's a thin line
between those two things it is it is but
you don't want to treat them like a
child you want to treat them like an
adult with respect when you approach
them all right Tara thank you so much